what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to the reunion between ksi
and dg um as you guys know i don't know
these people so sorry if i
said their names wrong but before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
as usual if you guys have any videos
that you want to request for me to react
to send them to me
on instagram it's just easier that way i
have them all like
lined up so if you guys have any
requests send it to me there
all right
what's up guys it's uh stevie i'm with
jj
you know you don't understand how many
people are [ __ ] gassed right now
yeah so happy to see this it's uh it's
crazy
we uh we talked from a little bit and
yeah no now we're here
hey what's up man what's up lizzy
how are you doing i'm good i'm good you
know
obviously um obviously you took it now
yeah
at least you know black lives matter
than that
[Laughter]
every bad person wearing that i guess
you know the reason why i took a knee
right yeah because you were unfair
yeah yeah i was i was done you were you
were
passed out i was so guest yeah i could
see
from vinnie's face that he didn't want
to hit me anymore oh really honestly
when i went down he like completely like
retreated
he's a good kid he he's he is a good kid
honestly yeah yeah like i said you lost
an anime character
no no no no huge respect to vinnie like
i've all the titles like i [ __ ] with him
the most yeah
like he was he was really cool and he
came off really
came off really well so yeah i know big
reigns but
he's still lost yeah i know owen too
damn that's what i would do if my
brother lost a boxing match a tail
who the [ __ ] i missed on the feed over
here and then mister
it's the journeyman over here oh my god
you know most people when they take an
l they uh completely just yeah
you know revamped themselves so you need
two apparently
no no i i mean i'll two girls too
back stronger i'm not scared to get in
the ring
i actually really enjoy it it's just
what's the problem
it's yeah it's literally just it's just
the hard work yeah
i said i'm too used to shortcuts yeah i
know
that's my issue so and you said it
yourself you can't cheat boxing that's
it you can't it's actually impossible
yeah especially if the guy is fitter
than you [ __ ] that's all vinnie hacker
was just
fit we knew he was going to come in fit
that's why the plan was
knock him out first round but
he uh clearly weathered the storm yeah
because fitness already will also bring
you uh
make you more durable so once
once the first equipment and i was like
yeah
well yeah i mean [ __ ] vic and what what
they called
their [ __ ] vic's gmo like
terrible terrible mindset terrible
game plan they tried no well
i mean i guess it's not all their fault
it's also your fault
but i mean they're not great let's be
honest
you have gone to them twice and lost
twice because of them
i mean you know i don't want a bad mouth
then but
you know they they could have done
better
of course i i i could have done a
hundred percent
because he did tell me to do runs and i
was always doing the bare minimum of my
runs like you were saying do a mile do a
two mile run
and i was just maybe doing like a
kilometer or something like that
who you chewing yeah i know i'm cheating
myself so
yeah that's what i mean so like it's
it's not i guess his
oh well no wonder he got his ass game
plan was for me to knock him out because
he
really knew the fitness wasn't there the
thing that should have been there he
should have just taken you out the fight
but i guess money in it
question would you
how much money would it take for you to
get your ass kicked let me know in the
comments because
if i got my ass kicked like by another
girl i don't think it would take that
much money
i don't know what it depends how good is
she you know
best believe whereas vidal my current
trainer
they would have just taken it was me
they were taking me out the fight
i was like your love will finish them
like no no no i'm not going
to put you in danger like that
there's just no point there's no need
life is more than just money
and fame yeah so i mean
they're getting a [ __ ] ton i hate no
yeah
the instagram is just a shut up you
[ __ ] fat [ __ ]
i'll be honest the only person who
really like
if it wasn't for dunya i've never been
way fatter
yeah like junior is the one who really
like knuckled down being like stop this
stop that
good on her for doing that she's like
you can even ask
like well i mean at least someone like
someone at least tried to help you i
mean she tried but obviously i always
was like nah it's all right it's okay
that's it ultimately it's all up to you
all right yeah
big big up dunya but end of the day
it's you like it's all on you bro
you are you and if you don't put in the
work you're not gonna win
i mean you still got a fan base you
still got people who love and support
you
honestly you should take a long-ass
break
i mean that is the that is the plan i
want to come back when
you know you want to come back chiseled
ripped yeah
yeah i mean if you can do it and i know
you can then do it that's when i'm gonna
come back
until then i'll just you know i'll just
put my head down
ultimately it's it's it's also it's
maybe you fix your hair style what is it
a little bit
it's just a bit basic in it what was the
last time you had a fade
i've never
this is just dad's hair ultimately it's
all
a mentality thing i know once i get
ripped my mentality will change
everything will change your mentality
changes
when your mentality changes so
you training and all that that's your
mentality training
it's not like it would just go oh my
once you've got a great body and all
that your
mentality doesn't just go okay time to
switch
time to be an athlete now you already
made that
uh change ages before why are you
i actually will say just like i played
three different sports in college and
you can tell
which athletes like have the heart and
have like the dedication to really
make the most of your ability and which
ones don't it's very apparent to see
oh no wait i turned the sound off okay
put in out of shape
yeah i mean look you can still enjoy
yourself
have fun you don't have to be [ __ ]
ripped chiseled
but when it comes to a fight you have to
be repetitive or you have to be in
insane shape you need to be fit i mean
andy ruiz is still able to last
12 rounds if you don't have much energy
a lot of times
just stand there you don't it's not
moving much
just stand there every time someone
tries to attack you
counter boom and then you just preserve
your energy throw a jab here and there
this is you conserving your energy you
you just
on him the whole time on him bang bang
you know
what you said is so true like uh i'm an
easy fight
like people you are if they want to just
make a name for themselves they fight me
they're pretty much because you still
got a big name it's not like
yeah no one cares about you yeah so that
can't be the case
look at this yeah yeah no no it's
he's yeah he's been he's been dope what
the hell
he's just too damn nice and he's 18 he's
a kid
yeah it's crazy and yeah i've seen i've
seen this video that
yeah how what did you think when you
watched the video i actually looked i
loved it yeah like i was i was there was
a part of me thinking
if he thinks i'm being negative or i'm
trying to attack him then i can't help
myself
then he you for i i was like you've
you're actually lost
you're actually gone yeah no it was
actually really good so
when i didn't see you tweet or make an
instant video
i was like okay he's actually listening
oh so yeah obviously like i'm gonna be
myself i'm gonna
there's nothing worse than a sore loser
like
that's very true there's nothing worse
than someone that's like complaining
about the outcome
all the time on social media after that
loss i slept
and i had a dream about me being in
cornfield yeah yeah bro yeah
but i've got a clowny bro this is what
it is i'm still gonna you know make
jokes here and there but you came out
looking like mike tyson
and ended up looking like solomon in 12
years of sleep
looking like mike tyson looking like
sullivan yes
[ __ ] man oh so that tower was dead
where did you find the towel oh no
i'm not even gonna lie i did not watch
the fight
so i didn't realize it came out it was
fixed like this so
um it was actually from the hotel
we uh oh my god bro he was like [ __ ] man
maybe jesus can save me maybe
mike tyson's [ __ ] aura might save you
wow all right well far enough yeah fair
enough
he's not clown on deji he lost and it's
okay i understand that he was not in
shape but please
jesus christ look at me you look like
[ __ ] fam i'm not even
like [ __ ] damn like
it's just i i haven't actually watched
the fight back
or anything i i just refused to because
i i was just so disappointed
no phone number like i can't i mean i'm
sure you will
eventually but yeah all in due time
no rush best response for now yeah i
mean that was just me saying i need to
take a break
yeah that's what i needed yeah i need to
take a break
that's
i was wondering when we're going to get
people clowning you
well same thing with bryce at least he's
being like
like a good sport about it oh my gosh
that's so
that's all i had all this all this i
know he's he's another one he's uh
he's lovely too i mean i i know no so
realistically let's be honest he did
he did sell the fight he got you
involved and you just boosted
sales yeah but i i don't know i for me
i'm always just like just be real
like the brief between me and logan it
was real
and like yeah we still i guess we
respect each other but it's not like
i'm messaging all the time it's not like
we're cool like that
jake me and jay obviously we don't
[ __ ] like each other
yeah that's obvious and like that's real
but that's just how i
am like i've always been real and i just
it's just easy to be real
yeah so when you said you trained five
times a day no that five times a day was
in cancun
but i but so you decided to train five
times a day
what a week before the fight yeah
[Laughter]
was like literally the worst strategy
because like the week before we had a
big game or something
they would not oh my gosh
they would not have us train that much
no so you know
i went to cancun 197 pounds
so and then i had to get to 185 pounds
so i had to starve myself literally just
pineapple
uh green juice which had like celery all
of that and then just water
that's all i had and i would run every
day
like so many times i'll go on the bike
cycle do the ellipticals do everything
i did all of that junior even did it
with me well you shouldn't have been 197
in the first place yeah oh that's close
to my [ __ ] weight
yeah i was uh yeah we were told late
about
the what weight we have to be so yeah
well then that's the fall of social
clubs but i mean social gloves
i mean first of all a terrible company
the whole gib
and um what's his name taylor holder
situation
like that was a huge [ __ ] up like the
the whole thing was just a shamble like
yeah good on austin for winning but yeah
[ __ ] me man that whole thing was a mess
but you know this makes me look
way fatter yeah i would see a little bit
hunched over but now this
you are out of shape you have minded
yeah you had man tits bro like it was
sad i was like
i'm bro my mouth was open i couldn't
believe it
oh wow yeah like because you're saying
how much you trained
it's just you've done it all wrong no
it's serious no it's no i know no excuse
it's uh it's still out of shape it's
just it's probably this is from obese to
overweight
literally pretty much the same thing
and then yeah i saw this yeah yeah give
him close to something he's saying
gibbs lovely yeah of course i know he's
a dope guy
he's funny he's funny he is funny as
hell he's
i didn't i he kind of like took me by
surprise
why because i i think i'm hated
by the whole uk youtube community
and then give was because of our beef
so i feel like oh they had beef
when i don't even know i'm just like oh
dizzy [ __ ] him man he's a [ __ ] so i
was just like okay so that's why i kind
of just isolated myself no
there should never be a situation where
people just hate you
because of our beef like that's
that's stupid that's well that's
yeah that's one of the dumbest things
i've ever heard
you shouldn't that should never have
been why would anyone hate you because
it's the situation between me and you
like no one should get involved really
like obviously you know people like
keemstar or scarce etc
it's news in it a new cell so they're
obviously gonna
you know no one hates you the hitch no
that's why
that's what i thought until like i don't
know like when i saw gabe like he was
just it's like
it was like whoa like even after my
fight
he came in and just gave me a hug
yeah because he knows what it's like to
lose he was
he was like the nice i think
i mean people came up to me but no one
came to my changing room
yeah to like saying he's the only one
who did yeah
because he knows how it feels no cameras
anything he just came in on his own
yeah that's how i know he's like an
actually genuine person there's a lot of
genuine people
in this space stage yeah there's a lot
of cool
dope people yeah okay and always there's
a lot of fake
twice there's a lot of people who
pretend that one thing but they're
another thing but yeah
yeah don't don't think everyone just
hates you that's just
it's not the right mindset don't always
don't already have something in mind go
oh okay this everyone thinks this yeah
it's not always well a lot of times
people aren't even thinking about you as
much as
you think like people really don't care
okay yeah that's my bad then lizzie will
not return
back to youtube until he has a six-pack
yeah who's the source is close say who's
this
yeah no that's the thing i have no idea
so i'm thinking you i i don't talk to
keemstar
i know you don't like him do you i don't
like him fair enough i think he's
i know not many people not many uh
people do like him
i think he's cool but i mean like
everyone's gonna be cool with me i'm
okay
signing it no one really wants to be on
my bad side
it says sources closely yeah i don't
know but i mean like either way
like it's low-key true yeah you
shouldn't return
i i mean not back to youtube you
shouldn't return back to boxing
unless you have a [ __ ] like six-pack
or ripped bro
like you need to be shredded like as
soon as my fitness
ripped everything is just like perfect
do you guys think he'll actually go back
because
it sounds like he was really unprepared
so i just wonder if like he would even
go back to boxing after that
that's when i'm gonna fully return i was
like the one predicted to win by a lot
i was minus like 500 i'm like holy [ __ ]
so i'm like i have to perform so then
obviously
i'm thinking i'm gonna go through vinnie
easy
mm-hmm i've seen him i've seen his
things him doing his hooks that
like no offense if he's watching i've
seen him doing his hooks he's trash
like i've seen him doing the pads he's
terrible
and then i lose i'm just like
[ __ ] man i suck listen when he was in
the corner uh talking to me i was just
usually saying i'm a failure
yeah we all heard and he was just
he was just hugging me like
it didn't make me feel at ease but it
also made me feel like
what the [ __ ] because i love boxing what
was the last fight you watched
the last boxing fight i watched was
believe saunders vs canelo okay what did
you think of that fight
so canelo is disgusting
he was doing power punches throughout
the whole round every like every round
i think i'm the wrong person to react to
this i have no idea what they're talking
about
and he just it's like he is unlimited
like that's what i want i want to be
able to be just doing
like huge bangs and just stamina which
is
not even depleted yeah ditch i don't
think you understand how hard
can i know canelo yeah works bro
i mean that's it bro that's the thing
like it's not all about
i mean yes there's a level of talent but
ultimately
if you're training hard then you're
gonna do well
yeah i don't know what other boxing
match has really been on i guess
i i guess the next one i want to watch
is um
deontay what against fury yeah
i've been trying to see how wilder's uh
improved i would i want him to win
i just want to see a good fight i'm not
really fast
it wins yeah uh taylor surprised me but
i feel like it was nerves
maybe yeah as well as like also
why crate was just ridiculous disgusting
he just didn't
stop stop uh bring home that yeah this
was there
yeah that's a bit awkward
[Music]
i mean what video was this
[Music]
oh
i really like how good of a sport he is
like he doesn't seem bitter at all
actually this that's what we saw
we saw we just saw that that's what we
saw
well then paul's in your court man
go ham all right and there is no beef
between us
we've somewhat squashed it i mean
there there was beef i i do admit i was
in the wrong
for a lot of it i shouldn't have i was i
guess i was thinking irrationally
like i said you can always just talk to
me okay
i'm not some god
okay you can't get in contact with me
like i'm a normal human being
damn
hmm well
if you made it this far i'm sorry i
think i was the wrong one to react to
this video because i have no idea what
they're talking about but
i actually really enjoyed how he was a
really good sport about everything
because a lot of guys like get bitter
after they lose in like
fights or games or whatever but let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or you disagree
let me know what you want me to react to
next time and do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification bell